good afternoon everyone
with so much going on in the world right
now sometimes easy to forget about
America's commitment here in Afghanistan
but the world should know that the Trump
administration hasn't forgotten American
people have not forgotten
we must represent their interests here
as ardently as ever it's why was a
critical time for me to make it back to
Afghanistan there have been a number of
errands sometimes different reports over
the past few months about American
diplomacy regarding Afghanistan I want
to make sure today to set the record
straight as president Trump has said
after almost now two decades of war in
Afghanistan an hour has come for peace
for the last nine months the United
States has facilitated a peace process
intent on protecting our national
interests while convening all the
parties for inter-african ago she ations
that will allow Afghanistan fashion of
political settlement and determine the
future for their country I mean my in my
meeting with President Ghani and chief
executive Abdullah we agreed that peace
is our highest priority and that
Afghanistan must never again serve as a
platform for international terrorism I
thanked President Ghani and chief
executive Abdullah for their long-term
partnership and support for Special
Representative Khalil Asaad on these
important issues as you're aware the
United States and the Taliban reached an
agreement in principle in January that
any comprehensive peace agreement must
address four interconnected issues
counterterrorism foreign troop presence
in traffic and dialogue leading to inter
Afghan negotiations as well as a
permanent ceasefire regarding terrorism
we've made a made real progress and are
nearly ready to conclude a draft text
outlining the Taliban's commitments to
join fellow Afghans and ensuring that
Afghan soil never again becomes a se
even for terrorists in light of this
progress we've begun discussions with
the Taliban regarding foreign military
presence which today remains
conditions-based and while we've made
clear to the Taliban that we're prepared
to remove our forces I want to be clear
we've not yet agreed on a timeline to do
so there should come as no surprise but
sometimes our adversaries announced
things that just aren't true I want to
reassure you that we hold detailed
discussions with the government
Afghanistan in parallel with our talks
with the Taliban ambassador bass general
Miller ambassador Leila's I have worked
diligently to ensure that we are fully
aligned in our approach and it was great
to be here today with President Ghani
all sides agree that finalizing a u.s.
Taliban understanding on terrorism and
foreign true presence will open the door
to enter Afghan dialogue and negotiation
that next step is at the heart of our
effort we are not and will not negotiate
with the Taliban on behalf of the
government or people of Afghanistan
rather we're working to reach Afghans
together at the negotiating table decide
the future of their own country
collectively and when that table is put
together it'll be a large table it's
crucial to include not just the table
under the government also
representatives from opposition parties
civil society including women in youth
as for our next diplomatic steps we
welcome Germany's commitment with Qatar
to convene and enter Afghan dialogue
next month this is an opportunity for
Afghans to endorse the urgent need for
inter Afghan negotiations simultaneously
the United States is laying the
groundwork for inter Afghan negotiations
to begin as soon as possible ejective of
those negotiations is where Afghans to
agree on a timeline and a political
roadmap for reaching a comprehensive
peace agreement not America's world to
dictate the outcome of those
positions we've been clear that's the
success or failure of the bilateral
relationship and Afghanistan's
relationship with the international
community including the donor community
we'll rest a part on what Afghans do to
maintain the civil rights of women and
minorities and preserve the gains of the
last 18 years I should add that not just
sharing the views of the United States
my words today reflect an international
consensus for peace my thanks go out to
neighboring countries who have supported
the process and which tend to benefit
tremendously from regional integration
that will for surely follow up from
peace we also sufficient appreciate the
support of our NATO allies and our
partners who serve alongside us and
resolute support his ongoing commitment
to the people of Afghanistan will be
critical in the post peace era the
trilateral consensus that we issued a
partnership with China and Russia as
well as the principles issued by the
United States Europe group or further
signs of the international community's
support for this peace process Pakistan
has a particularly important role to
play in this process and in the
promotion of peace and stability in the
region progress has been made and we
will continue to look to Pakistan for
practical measures cooperation on peace
talks and the implementation of any
agreement and I've said the word peace
more than half a dozen times it's our
priority but the procedure piece should
not wait till the Afghan presidential
election election planning must go
forward without delay as we pursue the
peace that Afghans deserve I urged the
Afghan government the Independent
Election Commission and all political
stakeholders to take all necessary steps
to ensure that the elections are
credible as we work to facilitate a
political settlement to the war in
Afghanistan we're also working with the
Afghan government and the international
community to lay the groundwork for a
stable and prosperous post-settlement
future for Afghanistan that's why today
beyond the meetings that I had at the
palace I had a number of internal
meetings today to dig into plans for our
future robust diplomatic security and
development presence the United States
will help Afghans preserve the gains of
the past 18 years
by supporting States ability to govern
[Music]
we have a peace deal before September
1st that's certainly our mission
second last question I want to get to
which was look we understand that the
tariff will remain and President Trump
has made clear that ensuring the
terrorism wherever we find it something
[Music]
Hey
Thank You mr. secretary you've talked
about this in the past but can you give
us anything concrete about ways in which
Iran has increased their involvement in
Afghanistan to make the peace process
more difficult then secondly I'd like to
give you an opportunity to respond to
what Iran said today they said that the
president rouhani said that the White
House is quote afflicted by mental
retardation and quote and said that the
path toward diplomacy is closed with is
it sanctions surely as for your first
question I can't share a lot more with
you about
involvement here in Afghanistan I would
say this it is not in Iran best interest
to undermine this peace process I would
hope that they could see that that they
could see that every regional players
best interest that this peace process
move forward after 18 years this is this
is something that that makes no sense
for all of the countries in the region
in in western Afghanistan has a long
border with Iran and to have a
reconciliation process move forward here
would be in that country's best interest
and so we'll continue to do the security
measures that we need to do here in
Afghanistan should Iran seek to further
destabilize the on-the-ground activities
here but I hope that they will not also
choose not to undermine the political
process the reconciliation process in
which we're engaged I've been in
meetings all day I hadn't seen the
statements that you that you read to me
today from the Iranians I can only say
this for 40 years Iran has engaged in
terror all around the world and they
continue to be the largest destabilizing
force throughout the Middle East so your
representation of what they said today
is right that's a bit immature and
childlike but know that the United
States will remain steadfast in
undertaking the actions though the
president laid out in his strategy to
create stability throughout the Middle
East which includes the campaign that we
have the economic campaign the pressure
campaign that we have on the Islamic
Republic of Iran
the peace process will move forward it
will take time America's presence here
will always we will always do the right
thing to protect American interests
whether that's Isis here whether that's
a risk of al-qaeda resurgence the United
States will always take the actions that
it needs to take to protect its interest
I don't want to get into I'll leave to
the department events to talk about
troop levels force posture regional
activities on how it is we would
guarantee or reduce the risk of that but
I don't think any terrorists should ever
underestimate America as well and
capacity ensure that we protect American
interests from terrorism thank you all
very much
[Music]